this is a production of Cornell
University Librarian I'd like to thank
all the grad students for organizing
this is a real honor to be invited by
the grad students which is a good
indication that there are memories of my
plant breeding 40:30
lectures is fading away I think we've
got the the sound issues worked out here
but if if you're having trouble on zoom'
just send a chat and Kevin here will
give me the high sign and welcome John
Mahoney it's good to see you again
my former summer scholar who's a grad
student at UConn maybe future postdoc
we'll see so I'm going to talk about our
hemp breeding program and I want to
highlight here at the beginning that I
do have a grad student in postdoc
working on this project now so Jacob
who's here we started in the fall and
Craig Carlson who does PhD in my lab and
is online but they only started in the
fall and we've been doing this for about
two years now so a lot of the work has
been done by our technical staff so I
really need to highlight a lot of work
that was done by Jamie Crawford and
Julie Hanson and Don buy-ins lab and
Rebecca will ku is my lead technician so
I'm going to
with a little background about cannabis
and let me just say there's a dual
meeting in my title from gray area to
Gold Rush it's not only referring to the
economic situation and the interest in
cannabis right now but it also refers to
the scientific situation right so a lot
of the information about cannabis is in
a gray area it's on websites that I
probably shouldn't be navigating to on
the Cornell Network and now that hemp is
legal and cannabis overall is fully
legal in Canada there is a real gold
rush for scientists there's we learn new
things every day about cannabis because
there's been very little research on
cannabis so it's really important to
make this point clear from the outset
there are some disputes about the botany
of cannabis that there are three species
or three subspecies indica sativa and
ruderalis they've been interbred at this
point and we don't really have access to
the native land races so I'm just gonna
call it cannabis sativa the real
distinguished distinction between
marijuana and hemp is a legal one the
level of THC so hemp
sativa has been bred for hemp to produce
grain fiber and now CBD with a
percentage of THC below 0.3 while
marijuana has been bred to produce high
levels of THC so really they are the
products of reading but the legal
definition which is really important for
growers and for regulators and for law
enforcement refers to the level of THC
not really the botany
[Music]
so we grew a lot of hemp in this country
in this area we grew a lot of hemp
during colonial days hemp could actually
be used to pay your taxes to the king
and that hemp was used to make a rope
and sailcloth in the British Navy we
also used it during wartime so the
biggest hemp cultivation in the US was
in 1943 and you see here I think we have
to trust the USDA statistics
about 180,000 200,000 acres of hemp
grown in 1943 and if you if you look at
the states that are involved here this
was Wisconsin early on Kentucky Illinois
Minnesota Iowa Indiana those were the
main states okay it was largely illegal
or very difficult to grow after 1937
there was a tax that was imposed on
cannabis that essentially made it too
expensive to grow and then the
controlled substance act in 1971 made
cannabis illegal to grow overall in 2014
though in the farm bill there were
provisions enacted to allow pilot
programs authorized by States to grow
hemp for research and that could be
agronomic research new york interpreted
it to also include market research so
new york approved its pilot program in
late 2015 and cornell got its growers
license we got license number two in the
state in early 2016 and we started
cultivating a hemp at the end of that
growing season so here's the interesting
situation is that we have a reasonable
market for hemp products it's not a huge
market in 2017 eight hundred and twenty
million dollars it's a very diverse
market as you see but at that time all
of the hemp products were being imported
because we didn't grow any him really
so one hundred and five million dollar
market for textiles entirely coming from
China and Patagonia has a pretty good
line of hemp clothing that you can
purchase there's a huge market for hemp
seed oil incorporated into personal care
products lotions soaps lip balm so that
picture is products made in Newark New
York
so panda deodorant no lip balm and then
there are very interesting industrial
applications that's a picture of a hemp
insulation that could be a replacement
for fiberglass wall insulation made by a
company in Louisville Kentucky
it's also a fantastic food product so
the grain goes into the granola so that
Evoque is a granola product made in
Rochester and Genesee brewery has just
announced three flavors of beer that
they're going to make from hemp grain so
very diverse market opportunities
up until now entirely supplied by hem
imported into this country
that's why legislators were so
interested in legalizing hemp why don't
we just grow it here and fully you know
fully market the opportunities here now
the big opportunity and the big
explosion the Gold Rush is in CBD
cannabidiol a compound will talk about
the biochemistry a little bit later in
the same bio synthetic pathway is THC
but very different pharmacological
activity so it has been approved as of
medicine very effective treatment for
childhood epilepsy reducing daily
seizures for children with Trivette
syndrome from 25 to 30 seizures a day
down to maybe one or two so very
effective for epilepsy and then a lot of
anecdotal data so this market is
spreading through word-of-mouth that it
is effective for other neuromuscular
symptoms muscular dystrophy Parkinson's
disease restless leg syndrome it's also
effective against anxiety and there are
good animal studies with anxious mice
they become less anxious and it helps
people sleep this also seems to be very
effective for chronic pain so actually
in the medical marijuana programs the
most common prescribed product is a
50/50 mixture of CBD and THC the CBD
counteracts the psycho act
of effects of THC and provides a broader
spectrum of pharmacological benefits
so that market is estimated to grow to
potentially two billion in 2020 it may
already be at two billion and twenty two
billion by 2022 so 90% of the hemp
growers in the country are growing to
produce CBD so here's the other aspect
of the goldrush the acreage has expanded
has tripled every year for the last
three years and I expect it will triple
again this year so again according to
the 2014 farm bill states had to pass
individual pilot programs by now 41
states have enacted hemp bills you can
see those white states that are the ones
left out I was just giving a seminar at
Ohio State
no hemp in Ohio we have some guests here
from Iowa
there's no hemp in Iowa so quartet Oh
what do you even do or now South Dakota
actually had legislation that they just
voted down and the governor is pretty
firmly against hemp in South Dakota
Georgia is working on it Texas is
working on but the big states are
Kentucky Oregon Colorado North Carolina
and New York where the top five so again
starting in 2016 pretty much the first
opportunity for states to grow after the
2014 farm bill about ten thousand acres
and by now this year I predict will be
up to 250 to 300 thousand acres
nationwide the other aspect of gold rush
for the students in the audience
audience is in jobs so I've seen an
estimate of in the next two years
500,000 jobs in the cannabis industry
and we will be launching certificate
programs and PS programs Carl and
buckler is teaching a course in cannabis
biology this fall so students will start
signing for up for that on Monday
so in response to this opportunity to
start cultivating hem in New York Chris
smart the director of the school of
integrated plant science assembled a
multidisciplinary team we've been
working very well together together with
10 Cornell Cooperative Extension
specialists across the state and with
New York State Ag and markets we have
conference calls every two weeks
covering pretty much all aspects of the
crop from plant breeding to pathology
entomology seed science biochemistry
tissue culture microbiome research we're
trying to do it all and I think we
probably now have the largest and most
comprehensive academic research team in
the country part of that is because a
very enthusiastic and generous support
from the governor and the legislature so
in early 2017 the governor committed
five million dollars for academic
research in hemp some of that went to
Morrisville State College but we at
Cornell have benefited from almost four
million dollars of that five million so
far including 2 million for our breeding
program so cannabis is a very diverse
crop you sell the diversity of market
classes market opportunities but it's
also grown in very different ways in the
field either can be grown in the
greenhouse or in controlled environment
settings or CBD it's grown similar to
tobacco or tomatoes so in Kentucky in
North Carolina it has been relatively
easy for the tobacco growers to
transition to hemp grown under raised
beds with trickle irrigation planted
from transplants hand harvested dried in
tobacco barns and hand stripped so a lot
of that is hand labor we'll talk about
that a little bit later we have some
growers that are growing hemp for baby
greens and marketing it at Whole Foods
in New York City for twelve or thirteen
dollars a clamshell but traditionally
hemp has been grown for grain as
crop planted with us cereal grain drill
harvested with a combine and four fiber
again planted in high-density as a field
crop harvested with a sickle bar mower
and bailed with a large round baler so
quite a diversity of cultivation methods
it's also very interesting crop in terms
of its reproductive biology and you know
I've done a lot of work on willow which
is another dioecious crop we've been
doing a lot of work recently studying
the sex determination region and sex
chromosomes in the salic AC so it's a
logical transition for us to start
working on sex dimorphism and sexually
dimorphic patterns of gene expression in
heme the cultivars are either dioecious
meaning pretty much a 50/50 mix of male
plants which you can see here senesce
before the females producing the pollen
and the female setting the grain heads
here
there are some variants that are
Manisha's that produced both male and
female flowers on the grain heads those
are some of our best producing grain
varieties right now or dual purpose
grain and fiber cultivars but for CBD
and THC you want to grow on pollinated
female plants those chemicals are made
on trichomes on the Brax of the female
floral tissue and when the females are
pollinated the levels of CBD or THC go
down two to threefold so there are
tricks to manipulating floral
development in cannabis gibberellic acid
promotes masculinity ethylene promotes
femininity female flowers so you can use
ethylene inhibitors to induce male
flowers on female plants the pollen
produced from those male flower parts
only have X chromosomes
so when you use that X pollen to
pollinate the female plants all of the
seed is xx so we call that feminized
seed and it's a way to plant out a field
and only get female plants which is what
you want right now that feminized seed
for CBD lines is selling for a dollar or
seed dollar seed so those folks who are
very good at doing this treatment
inducing male flowers on female plants
and generating you know tons of
feminized seed are making hundreds of
millions of dollars right now we have
some ideas about manipulating sex and
maybe generating some sterile plants
again we learn more about amp every day
one thing that Jacob haves has done he
has really contributed a lot over the
last few months there are some
y-chromosome specific markers and Jacob
has converted those into cast markers so
now we have good genetic tests for male
and female for XX or XY those genetic
tests are commercially available as well
so commercial growers can test their
plants
the only issue there is these companies
are charging ten dollars per sample so
if you want to do a whole field it's not
practical at this point we can do it for
our trials because we're only putting a
couple hundred plants out in the field
so doing two thousand tests I think
we're only dollar fifty maybe two
dollars a sample to get these assays
done so this is sort of an outline of
the way I'm going to organize the rest
of my talk as we think about
establishing an breeding program for a
new crop these are sort of the steps
that I envision that we need to take we
need to assemble some germ plasm we need
to characterize that germ plasm and
develop phenotyping techniques and look
at the traits that we want to start to
select for so I'll talk about the trials
that we've done over the last two years
for grain fibre and dual purpose grain
and fiber crops and we've also done one
year of trials to look at CBD slash THC
those are the main traits there we've
done some work together with Cornell
Cooperative Extension to model the cost
of production that's important in any
breeding program because you want to
breed for trace it will improve the
profitability of the crop and help us to
establish an idio type for what we're
breeding what are our breeding goals and
then based on the biology the trace that
we want to select forward the variation
that we see in the germ plasm that we
have and the crossing techniques
cannabis is a wind pollinated crop
highly outbreeding highly heterozygous
we need to develop a breeding strategy
and marker systems that we can
incorporate to do marker assisted
selection I just showed you one for male
male female sex but we'd eventually like
to be able to develop markers for
genomic selection okay so the first step
assembling germ plasm for the rest of
the breeders in the room when they think
about assembling germ plasm when mark
thinks about adding diversity to his
wheat breeding program he might go to
the green database and say oh let me
find some lines from Turkey or some
lines from other places to incorporate
so the USDA used to have a hemp germ
plasm collection when you go to grin you
see that there are a hundred and fifty
accessions in the database zero
available that's because that collection
was destroyed after the passing of the
Controlled Substances Act
so we do not have a u.s. hemp germ plasm
collection the Vavilov Institute has a
hemp germ plasm collection that's been
rather difficult for people to access I
was reading a paper yesterday about a
Canadian one of the pioneering Canadian
researchers in the 70s who did a
diversity study he accumulated a hundred
and fifty accessions including 75 or 80
from the Vavilov Institute when the
Canadian government found out that he
had all this they destroyed his whole
collection
my colleague George we blend at
University of Mississippi Minnesota
collected a lot of feral populations so
that's another thing that we can look at
is there's a lot of ditch weed out there
I showed you the states that grew all
the hemp in World War two Iowa Illinois
Minnesota Wisconsin and Nebraska and
those states still have a lot of fuel
hemp on the landscape George we blend
characterized some of that fear of hemp
under DEA scrutiny and then when he was
done with a study they destroyed it all
so that has been the history of trying
to accumulate hemp germ plasm over the
last couple of decades but now with a
20-18 farm bill hemp has been taken off
of the schedule 1 controlled substance
list so now we should be able to work
freely without the scrutiny of the DEA
although we still need to prove to
people that it's hemp and not marijuana
right so this is an interesting map
because you see a lot of hemp where I
don't really think is growing this
includes cannabis sativa and it's
actually on five state noxious weed
lists and I'm not sure they they fully
interpreted weed there properly because
if you look at West Virginia it's only
in a few counties in West Virginia it's
not like an invasive weed but it's a
weed and they put it on the noxious weed
list in western in Minnesota I I'm more
confident that ditch weed really has
spread outside of its range of
cultivation so we do have intentions now
that we can collect hemp freely without
the scrutiny of the DEA of doing some
excursions to the Midwest and finding
some feral hemp populations we had found
three feral hemp populations in New York
already but it was
pretty well eradicated so the other
possibilities to look to the native
range of hem which is in Central Asia
and I was very lucky to visit Kazakhstan
last year where they have two hundred
thousand acres of wild hemp growing and
maybe we can cultivate those
relationships that was related to our
historic relationship in Geneva in the
Assembly of the apple germ plasm
collection and numerous collection trips
that my colleagues made to build our
apple germ plasma collection in Geneva
so I'm hopeful that we can do the same
thing with cannabis but it is highly
illegal in Kazakhstan so we will need to
have some influence some influence on
the government in Kazakhstan maybe find
an oligarch who can help us make some
collections there in Kazakhstan also
Pakistan who's Becky Stan India you can
see how hemp moved from that native
range around the world as it was
cultivated over the last thousand years
so the
question is a diversity of that germ
plasm and the current marijuana germ
plasm really has very low diversity so
this is one of the better examples this
is a 3d PCA on the web that you can play
around with you could click on each
point and see which sample it is this is
a company called Philo's in portland
oregon and for full disclosure I'm
serving on their scientific advisory
board right now but they had a business
of collecting samples doing amplicon
sequencing and then creating this
diversity map on the website so that
everyone who has their own genetics this
is a term we learned early on in the
hemp business he said if you're in the
business you have your own genetics
which means where did you get your own
genetics and how is it yours now because
I'm a breeder and in order to protect
that and demonstrate that your own
genetics is different from anyone elses
you would send a sample to Philo's and
they would put it up on the FiOS galaxy
here and you could prove that your stuff
is different from everyone else's so
just looking at the color codes here
hemp are the yellowish dots here the
green is what people are calling
landraces and again these are just
samples that are submitted by people
willing to pay $300 per sample to get it
onto the Pylos galaxy the CBD lines are
all over here on the left and light blue
and you see there is a lot of
relatedness here in CBD land and the
light purple and red here are marijuana
lines so that's very interesting go play
around with it it's a very cool
interface it's something that we hope to
sort of reproduce ourselves we've got
some GPS samples being sequence right
now but we hope to go to a sequence
capture genotyping system which has
worked very well in poplar and Willow so
we have accumulated germ plasm as we
have been able to all of the commercial
cultivars are protected by those
breeding companies they won't allow us
to breed with them pretty much we have
one or two relationships with breeding
companies but the rest of the breeding
companies are very protective in fact
some of the CBD most popular CBD
companies will not send me material just
to put in trials because they're afraid
that I will start breeding with it so
people are very protective of their germ
plasm and you really have no idea what
its pedigree is where it came from
whether it's him or not him so we hope
to reproduce this ourselves
ok moving
to phenotyping and trialing this is not
only for us to demonstrate the utility
of different cultivars for our growers
in New York but also for us to look at
the traits of the germ plasm that we
have available so we've been doing this
in small plot trials sharing a lot of
equipment with the Sorel's group so we
appreciate that we're very grateful for
that
planting grain and dual purpose trials
at 15 live seeds per square foot which
was about 25 pounds to the acre the
fiber is planted at a higher density 30
live seeds per square foot or about 50
pounds to the acre and evaluating all of
these traits as best we can so hemp is a
very finicky crop to establish in the
field has very specific depth
requirements moisture requirements does
not like flooding at all so that's one
thing we've learned already in just two
years in 2017 we had very good
establishment and a good crop after it
germinates it will get about 4 to 5
inches tall and then sort of sit there
for 3 weeks
so I'll show you last year that was a
problem because we had about five or six
weeks with no rain but in 2017 we had
nearly perfect growing conditions and
you see after seven weeks that stuff is
five or six feet tall we're using a
small plot combine to harvest this and
now we have another L may go combine and
Geneva in addition to the one we have
here and it the cut to measure grain
yields and in 2017 we tested thirteen
commercially available certified grain
cultivars and got on average about
fourteen hundred pounds to the acre the
best cultivar and the best plot best
trial was nearly 2,400 pounds to the
acre where the average Canadian yields
is 800 to 900 pounds to the acre so I
think we have very good potential to get
high yields of grain production here in
New York State and it could be a good
rotation field crop with our other field
crops and offer more opportunities for
farmers
that grain is high in oil so 35 to 36
percent oil with a very healthy mix of
omega-6 and omega-3 fatty acids again
that oil is a good culinary oil not a
cooking oil but for salad dressings
pesto's other low temperature
applications because it has a very low
smoking temperature it's a good
replacement for fish oil because of that
omega-6 and omega-3 balance there and
again that oil is also a very good oil
for cosmetic or personal care products
it's also actually a good wood
preservative and a good paint once you
press for that oil there is a high
percentage of protein in the press cake
so this is from the bulk seed about 26
to 27 percent protein so in the press
cake you can get around 50 percent
protein so that's another good market
opportunity is you know gluten free soy
free sorry about that
gluten free soy free GMO free often
grown organic because there are no
pesticides registered for hemp right now
so if you use organic fertilizer on
certified organic land it's really not
that much different from conventional
cultivation and can be a good source of
protein for plant-based meats for high
protein smoothie drinks and and for
athletes
it's another market that we're trying to
tap into as well as for animal feeds so
there are groups now trying to get hemp
research done to have it approved as an
animal feed additive there studies
already research studies that show it's
a very good poultry feed and beef
growers in Colorado are really pushing
it because there some of them are
already using hemp and getting very high
quality beef
so in 2018 those trials were done only
in Ithaca and Geneva in 2017 and 2018 we
expanded to include Long Island and
Chazy
so covering the full latitudinal range
in New York States planted still a
little bit late from June 8th to June
20th but one of the main issues that
we've had is in acquiring seed getting
it imported under DEA restrictions so
we've always been a little bit late this
year we're gonna be spot on time I'm
sure of it
so six sites and we also did some larger
strip trials for combine demos so I put
up the list of cultivars here one thing
we learned in 2017 is that we needed to
break up our trials into blocks based on
maturity date so we put the early
maturing grain varieties in one block
the later maturing dual-purpose
varieties in another block and then the
fiber varieties which we're going to cut
with a sickle bar mower in a third block
so that's how I've got them organized
here one thing you see is that
there are big issues with seed quality
that the seed laws are really not being
enforced in hemp right now in the US and
when we get seed Lots from a breeder in
Oregon
he sent a seed with 39% germination most
of the commercial seed Lots that we've
gotten have been pretty good over 85%
but some of them coming in from Europe
not so good there are also differences
in thousand kernel weight so you can see
one here at 22 and one here under 12 so
that's a trait that we're interested in
looking at is seed size how it relates
to early seedling vigor and again yield
of oil and protein so 2018 was not a
perfect growing season again at five to
six weeks with no rain after planting
that allowed the weeds to take off as
the hemp was sitting there that tall and
in fact some of our early maturing grain
cultivar plots we lost to weeds we lost
it to the pig weed and then we got very
heavy rain later in the season and hemp
does not like flooding conditions so our
yields were much lower in 2018 highest
grain yield they're averaging 800 pounds
to the acre
keep this pewter river in mind here
because that's gonna play into our
longer-term breeding strategies looking
at dual purpose cultivars again a lot of
these have been bred in Italy France
Poland a couple from Canada here this is
the first u.s. certified cultivar from
John McCain's company in West genetics
in Colorado and again some that we've
gotten from some breeders in Oregon just
wanted to show you sort of the diversity
of where our germ plasm is coming from
again 2018 yields not nearly as good as
we would hope based on our 2017 results
definitely differences in site quality
hemp is a very nitrogen demanding crop
we've learned that and again very
intolerant of poorly drained soils but
we still have a lot more to learn about
that maybe a little bit of good news
from 2018 we planted these larger 2 to 3
acre fields for combine demos a couple
of weeks later than our cultivar trials
so they got the rain a little bit
earlier and here in this field of Anka
which is a Canadian cultivar that is
proving to be one of our better
cultivars where we got 1,300 pounds to
the acre dirty seed you know probably
about twelve hundred pounds clean so
again that's that's a reasonable yield
economically viable yield of seed I
think we can get it up over 1400 to
maybe 2,000 pounds to the acre
commercially
okay looking at fiber the best fiber
cultivars have been bred in Italy so far
although we just imported nine cultivars
from China so we'll be comparing Chinese
to Italian fiber cultivars this year and
in 2017 again a pretty good growing
season by the by harvest time there were
eight to nine feet tall forming a nice
dense canopy there which we harvest with
a sickle bar mower in 2017 we just
weighed the fresh weight with all the
leaves dried a subsample
but we realize that's not ideal we got
some criticism for not reading it so
this would be the normal process for
high fiber hemp is to cut it and leave
it on the field to Rhett allowing
nutrients to leach out of the tissue
back to the soil but also encouraging
microbial growth to separate the
high-quality bast fiber on the outside
of the stem from the woody herd tissue
in the middle so that it can then go to
be decor decay 'td and separated into
those two product lines the long fiber
and the woody herd 5-wood he heard
tissue so we attempted this in our
trials doing some reading to get then
dry straw weight and again we were
getting reasonably competitive
commercially viable yields of reddit
straw between three to four tons to the
acre and if the bast fiber is about 20
to 25 percent you're getting about a
thousand pounds of high-quality fast
fiber that you could use for rope or
fabric or bio composite materials so we
will
continue to do that type of cultivar
evaluation trying to encourage a grain
and fibre industry to develop in New
York State we really need a fiber
processor to come in and install the
decor decoding equipment so that we can
start to incorporate hemp into some of
these novel bio composite materials so
BMW mercedes-benz Porsche are using hemp
compressed panels and some of their
automobiles because it is lighter and
just as strong as other materials that
they can use
[Music]
okay moving on to look at CBD that's
what everyone's interested in on the
left there you see a commercial CBD
field growing in Orange County that was
planted from a clone so it looks very
uniform there in the field we planted
from seeds last year that we started in
the greenhouse and we didn't have those
sex markers developed yet so we were
hoping to see the male plants we didn't
have any feminized seed either so we
needed to wait for them to flower to
remove the male plants some of our lines
did that in the greenhouse but even
though we let them get way too tall
before and to them many of them did not
flower and we were out there every day
or every other day calling out the male
plants so that was a lot of work
it's why growers are willing to pay a
dollar per seed for feminized seed right
now is because if you plant dioecious
plants you have a lot of huge labor
labor requirement going out there
calling out male plants every day as
they come to flower I also did not have
a good representative sample of
commercially available cultivars we
really had wines from two breeders one
in Las Vegas and one in Oregon as well
as a couple of other lines that we
picked up but these were not stable as
you're going to see not stable
commercially ready CBD lines
this year I've been scouring the
internet talking to seed companies and
we have a pretty good represent
representative group of 30 cultivars
both feminized seed and female clones
and some dioecious lines that will sort
out the male's with molecular markers
ready to go for our trials this year so
we planted on two sites one in Geneva
one in Ithaca bluegrass lain under
plastic raised beds with plastic and
trickle irrigation but as you know in
actually I think this was right after
our field day in the second week of
August where we got three and a half
inches of rain that day not great for a
field day we had standing water in that
field and one thing we learned about him
is it does not tolerate standing water
within a week or so many of those plants
died that was a similar situation for
some of our commercial growers they lost
anywhere from 25 to 50 percent of their
plants if they were on a poorly drained
site some of them did okay with raised
beds but hemp does not tolerate flooding
and when you think of where the CBD hemp
industry has developed in Colorado and
Oregon that probably has not been a
typical problem in those environments we
sampled individual plants in our CBD
trial for cannabinoid analysis so that
picture on the left is how we clip the
entire shoot tip there and we would mill
that entire thing so it includes leaves
and stems as well as the little flower
Brax we harvested whole plants and hung
them in the greenhouse to dry this is
pretty typical of how many of the
commercial producers did it this year in
a barn with lots of fans and maybe they
had some dehydrators going on in there
dehumidifiers and
would you get on the end that picture on
the right is dried floral material which
we were then stripping by hand and again
that was the industry standard at that
point there are some machines that you
can run these stems through just strip
them off but a lot of it is handwork
okay so let's talk a little bit about
CBD biochemistry CBD and THC as well as
CDC are all derived from a common
precursor CB GA which is converted by
three highly similar enzymes tht HCA
synthase CBD a synthase and CBCA
synthase they are all over 90% similar
at the protein level so one thing that
Jakob is very interested in doing will
be a part of his dissertation research
is to do some directed evolution studies
to see what is involved in basically
converting a CBD a synthase to a THC a
synthase or a CBC a synthase there those
genes are also highly duplicated in the
genome and I'm going to show you that
actually the distinction between a hemp
type plant and a marijuana type plant
lies in a mutation in mutations in the
THC a or CBD a sand-based genes so lines
with a functional CBD a synthase have
non-functional or pseudogenes at th CA
synthase lines that have a deletion in
the CBD a synthase so a non-functional
CBD a synthase have functional THC a sub
bases and we can distinguish those with
codominant markers okay
the key thing is that as you're growing
these CBD lines which really have been
crosses between hemp and marijuana you
need to make sure that your THC levels
do not rise above 0.3 so that is a
matter of good farming because the CBD
and THC starts to accumulate at a
certain point after the start of
flowering in the female flowers but the
THC levels will continue to rise as the
plants get older so we've done all of
this work in collaboration with Joss
Joss Rose both with Trevor Yeats who's
in the room and Glen Phillipe postdocs
of Josas so Trevor did all of our 2017
samples in Glen analyzed about 1,200 of
our samples in 2018 and these are the
CBD concentrations that we got from that
material upwards of 8% commercially
people are getting hoping for 10 to as
high as 14 percent so these lines were
not really great averaging you know 5%
CBD but the bigger issue is that some of
these were producing a lot of THC they
had not been stabilized for low THC by
these two breeders that I got them from
in fact you know you see lines that were
close to three percent THC so we do have
a DEA registration for the marijuana
drug code so that's that's the way I
think we can continue to work on these
lines if we have the approval from the
state as well so this is an issue
we also see a diversity of other
cannabinoids CBC and CVG and there's
good evidence that a mixture of
cannabinoids also has pharmacological
effect it's not just purified CBD that
certainly does have certain effect but a
combination of cannabinoids can invoke a
different form of pharmacological
effects so people are very interested in
looking at lines with different
concentrations of the other minor
cannabinoids so to look at the economics
we also needed to measure biomass yield
so again we stripped all of those plants
by hand got about double the yield at
bluegrass Lane than we did in Geneva
averaging about a pound per plant which
is yeah a pretty good rule of thumb
averaged for the industry so now that
gave us the opportunity to do some
overall economic analysis john hancher
and CCE did this so first looking at
grain or fiber he estimated the input
costs the cost of hemp of grain or fiber
seed is about 250 a pound 25,000 pound
seed per pound so not $1 per seed
because he planted a higher density the
fiber input costs are a little bit
higher he estimated about a thousand
pounds of grain yield at a dollar 10 per
pound so $1,100 or so our gross revenue
for grain 8,000 pounds of v of dry straw
yield at 10 cents a pound
you get about 800 so it's in the range
of the revenue that you might get from a
current field crop if you can do a dual
purpose grain and fiber harvest you'll
increase your revenues okay here's the
goldrush growing CBD hemp in that
horticultural setting is very
labor-intensive right now people are
estimating 15 to 20 thousand dollars of
input costs per acre in the cost of seed
all that plastic mulch and irrigation
a lot of hand labor the average price
for CBD hemp is about $4 per percent CBD
per pound so if you're averaging 10% CBD
you can get about $40 per pound if
you're getting a pound per plant and
planting in you know 6 by 6 or 6 by 8
spacing
that's about 1,400 plants to the acre
you're averaging 1,400 pounds at $40 per
pound
$56,000 gross revenue per acre so those
are the back of the envelope
calculations that people are doing that
has encouraged this tripling of hemp
acreage every year for the last three
years net returns of over twenty
thousand dollars per acre I don't think
that's gonna last because of the labor
demands we can't keep tripling our labor
force in this current environment so I
think very quickly we're going to move
to a cultivation system that is based on
field crops dioecious field crops
planted mechanically harvested
mechanically so we are now breeding our
ideo type is a dual-purpose CBD and
grain cultivar if we get a fiber market
in New York State then we'll look at CBD
and fiber but I have already seen
commercial harvesting from a combine
with a modified conveyor system that
collects the fine leafy material off the
top of the combine sieve directs that
into a wagon diverting the straw back on
the field and collecting the grain in
the bin at the combine so a dual purpose
grain and CBD harvest and I think we
have some material that can help us get
to that point so if you look at this
cultivar here in Nebraska feral that we
got from a breeder in Oregon produced
about three to four percent CBD while
also producing about eight hundred
pounds to the acre of grain some of
these other ones puter river and
sterling gold also produced decent
yields of grain so we anticipated doing
some crosses of those with some of our
high CBD lines like a 2 R 4 and ac/dc
the issue that we ran into as Jacob has
developed markers for this functional
and non functional CBD a synthase is we
can now predict which lines our
marijuana type and which lines are
hematite based on the presence of those
functional non-functional CBD a synthase
markers initially he saw a very good
correlation with THC ratios with those
markers and then when we started looking
at populations as we planted them out in
the greenhouse to do crosses we found
that pewter River was over 90%
homozygous for the marijuana type non
functional CBD a synthase sterling gold
I think more than 80 percent and only
three individuals that were homozygous
for the hemp type functional CBD a
synthase here about 15 individuals right
so that's what we're selecting for our
the hemp type CBD a synthase genes and
some of those populations which came out
hot in the field we know had marijuana
type THC synthase genes so we have some
initial markers that we can use we have
some initial phenotypes in an idio type
that we're going for but again we're
learning more about hemp we have some
crazy ideas about developing triploids
and developing YY mail lines and so
hopefully come back in a few years and
we'll have some innovative stuff but
right now we're just learning everyday
so I'm going to wrap up that's these are
our future directions to continue to do
outreach to growers in New York by
evaluating cultivars this year we'll
have four CBD trial sites with upwards
of 30 different cultivars we're working
with companies to establish certified
seed production in New York building our
germ plasm collection characterizing
that for the traits that are important
and for genetic diversity collaborating
with biochemists to characterize
cannabinoids and terpenoids we can use
whether we can inbred in breed and
develop hybrid lines or develop sterile
lines those are the types of things
we're starting to look at and Matthew
Willman has been working on
transformation for eventual CRISPR
transformation CRISPR modification but
hemp is a challenging crop to grow in
tissue culture so need to thank my
funding sources all of our money so far
has come from New York State Department
of Ag and markets and Empire State
Development and please check out our
website and follow me on Twitter so I'm
happy to stop here and take any
questions are there quality or purity
standards relating to CBD sales in the
US so yeah so the question is are there
purity or quality standards so it's a
little bit of a tricky thing because CBD
as a prescription medicine is not
supposed to be sold outside of
prescription that prescription medicine
situation so the companies that are
selling it are selling it as a dietary
supplement and
they're not really putting the CBD
concentration on their labels they're
putting hemp extract so no the bottom
line is there are really are no
standards
it's very iffy you need to find a brand
that you trust that is doing their own
internal standard quantification of
their products and it may be a pure CBD
product or it may be a full spectrum
hemp extra
there are of course very strict
phonological standards for the
prescription medicine do you have you
measured inbreeding depression I guess
we have not yeah that's an interesting
question so I know there are people that
have been in breeding their lines for
quite a while and there are f1 hybrids
that are marketed but we have not gotten
that for ourselves
I was just wondering about the IDEO type
of getting CBD and grain I thought that
the pollination reduced the CBD
production yes so how I mean is there
it's just like a night like there are
there some plants that do both well is
that kind of the idea yeah so if we kept
those lines unpalatable but the fact
that they're pollinated it goes down
probably the three to four percent but
yeah I'm not fully convinced that I
think there's going to be variation in
that decline in CBD production after
pollination if we can get trichome
production on a wider diversity of
foliar tissue outside of just the floral
tissue then we can maintain higher
production of CBD but it's the bottom
line is how much CBD can you produce per
acre so at a higher density can you get
the same amount of CBD per acre as an a
low density horticultural planting where
you have high concentration plants so
kind of along those lines is that what
is the link between pollination and CDC
production is can you decouple that
connection exactly so that's a very good
question
can we decouple and exactly what is
happening upon pollination that's
triggering that I think there's some
evidence that the trichomes are
physically falling off is that right
Jacob
maybe so is is is that it that it that
you're losing trichomes or is it a down
regulation of the biochemical pathway we
really want to do a time series of
rna-seq experiments to look at the
changes in gene expression in a very
detailed way through through time at in
the floral maturation process to see if
we can figure out what's going on
is there ploidy variation in that asset
Ave and has anybody thought about making
auto Poli plates yeah
so we we are thinking about that a lot
because that's what we do in Willow we
make triploid willow that grow very well
so Jacob has been very good at at mining
the literature and there is some
evidence of natural tetraploid in India
I believe and there was a very recent
report out it's only a preprint right
now that N and E alabs which was one of
the marijuana companies in Canada has
doubled a genome and generated a
tetraploid hi um are there any efforts
to leverage natural diversity in other
members of the cannabis yeah I'm like
pops for example for the improvement
yeah so the question is can we
interbreed hops into cannabis sativa not
necessarily interbreed but just use you
know other genetic resources to maybe
understand what's going on yeah yeah I
don't know a whole lot I haven't had a
whole lot of time to study the botanical
diversity of the can of a see so I think
there there are opportunities there but
I'm not sure that that I think there
will be crossing barriers there yep
more urgently we're interested in
pathogens that can cross over between
Hopsin hemp and we have some initial
concerns about that maybe one more
question from Ithaca before we go to the
soon industry drying or any post harvest
yeah so the question is is there some
overlap between hops producers and hemp
producers we do have some growers who
grow both hops and hemp
I'm not sure that the volume of the hops
drying systems will meet the needs of
the hemp industry but yes people are
looking at everything
tobacco drying system hay drying systems
it's got to be low temperature but yeah
okay we have two questions from zoom
first from alfred who oh yes we'll see
BGA effect tissue culture or a plant
regeneration is any research about
blocking THC synthase to improve CBD
right so yeah that's certainly one of
the targets of genetic modification
would be a zero THC line by knocking out
thca synthase it is duplicated in the
genome some reports there are at least
seven copies upwards I think there are
reports of twenty to thirty copies of
THC a synthase but yeah that is that is
a key sort of gold and target would be
to knock out th CA synthase the other
question I'm not sure we know why hemp
is so recalcitrant in tissue culture but
I don't think it's related to
cannabinoid biochemistry because that's
only produced in the floral trichomes
next from Shelby Ellison how many of the
CBD females turned him from Aphrodite
yeah so hemp that's a great question
hemp is a very fickle plant and
regulating it sex and we definitely have
already seen genotypic differences in
how stable a female is we have one line
clonal line in the greenhouse that we've
grown for a year under high stress
conditions pot bound low nutrient and it
has stayed female solidly other lines
you fail to give them perfect water and
they'll start making male parts they go
hermaphroditic yeah it'd be very
interesting to try to sort out the
genetic basis for that and in our CBD
trial I think four of our lines went
hermaphroditic and again it's driving us
crazy because there's pollen being
produced in the middle of our CBD field
a final question from Ken what
concentrations of ethylene inhibitors
work for sex Monica's modification of
female lines yeah so we based our
research on a paper that just came out
from UConn but we only did in our
experiments we've only tried it on one
line they tried it on three lines and
did see gene
differences by genotype in the
sensitivity to silver thiosulfate which
is the ethylene inhibitor that they used
so I think there there are going to be
genotypic differences in that hormonal
control of flowering which are probably
related to the stability of femaleness
versus hermaphroditic we also tried we
tried to extend that study by using MCP
which is another commercial inhibitor of
ethylene action used in the apple
industry our particular line did not
respond to MCP at all still totally
female and we're very interested in
taking males and inducing female so we
want to do a lot of work we're doing
that with Bill Miller in horticulture
all right join me in thanking Larry
again this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu